what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have a lot of news in the world
of marvel some exciting some concerning
but a lot to break down we have news
about deadpool 3 good news about
deadpool 3. some news about thor love
and thunder some possible news about the
fantastic four in the mcu some cool
black panther 2 news an interesting line
from marisa tomei about the upcoming
spider-man movies and to top it all off
a bit of concerning news about morbius
so if you're excited to see morbius or
even if you're not you're gonna want to
hear this so let's break down everything
that you need to know about all of this
news that's come out in the recent past
couple of days and of course if you love
marvel and you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so let's go
ahead and start with deadpool 3 because
this is really cool news really exciting
news and it honestly could be a very
important point for marvel studios in
this time if you haven't noticed ryan
reynolds is kind of on fire right now
and he's kind of been on fire for the
past few years well for a pretty long
time and now it looks like he's about to
take it one step further as it's been
announced and reported by an article
with forbes magazine about ryan reynolds
and his companies maximum effort and
mountain it's been reported that maximum
effort is going to co-produce deadpool 3
with marvel studios this is pretty big
because we've only seen this before with
spider-man specifically of course tom
holland spider-man now before everybody
gets kind of concerned here about this
arrangement let me explain why it's
actually a very good thing and kind of
nothing like what's happened with
spider-man with spider-man sony had a
lot of the power because they're the
ones who owned the rights to the
character so even though it was a
partnership with marvel studios sony
basically had the ability at any point
in time to pull the character from the
mcu and give marvel studios no right to
use it at all i'm sure everybody
remembers a couple years back the heart
attack that sony and marvel studios gave
us when we didn't know if spider-man was
going to be staying in the mcu or not
because sony and marvel could not work
out a deal this is nothing like that and
there's no possibility of that happening
because marvel studios owns the rights
to deadpool but maximum effort is ryan
reynolds company and it's actually
fantastic that they are co-producing it
because that means ryan reynolds is
going to be even more hands-on with
deadpool than he's ever been before in
the history of the franchise which
probably means this is going to be the
best deadpool film yet especially if you
actually consider the updates that we've
gotten for deadpool 3. it's been
announced that director sean levy is
going to be directing deadpool 3 and he
just recently got done directing free
guy which of course starred ryan
reynolds as well and the atom project
that is now out on netflix which is also
a pretty fantastic movie this is also
good news on the rated r front now that
maximum effort is co-produced in the
movie i have no doubt that this movie is
going to be rated r also ryan reynolds
himself is helping write the script and
ryan reynolds had stated before that he
actually wants to be more hands-on with
deadpool with the future movies and it
looks like that is exactly what marvel
studios is letting him do which is
absolutely fantastic kevin feige truly
does know what is best for movies and in
this case i think everybody would agree
the best thing is to let ryan reynolds
kind of just handle it but that's not
all the good news that comes with this
co-production ryan reynolds stated in
the forbes article that deadpool 1 and
deadpool 2 really didn't have that big
of a budget so they had to make the most
out of something very little in which
they absolutely did deadpool and
deadpool 2 were fantastic but now
deadpool is over at marvel studios and
it's being co-produced by ryan
reynolds's company so needless to say
this movie is going to have a bigger
budget than the previous two films which
means they can do a lot more so all in
all without even knowing anything about
what the story could possibly be for
deadpool 3 deadpool 3 is looking pretty
good right now deadpool is over at
marvel studios now so he's in the mcu
and can interact with all of these other
characters break the fourth wall about
all of these other characters he's got
the money to back him up now we have an
amazing director for deadpool 3 and ryan
reynolds himself is super hands on so
hopefully deadpool 3 is the best
deadpool that we've gotten so far now
moving on to thor love and thunder and
the fantastic four there have been
rumors going around that null would
appear in thor love and thunder nola is
essentially the symbiote god he created
the symbiotes and he also created the
all black sword now eventually gore the
god butcher would go on to get the all
black sword and he would actually take
it from null as noah got into a fight
with another god fell to his planet and
was about to die so naturally it would
actually make sense that noel the
creator of the symbiotes would be in
thor love and thunder since score the
god butcher originally gets his sword
from no but it looks like this might not
be happening as somebody from the geeks
worldwide casey walsh has apparently
debunked this rumor stating no on
twitter now keep in mind anything is
possible and they are doing reshoots
right now but remember sony does still
have venom and all of the symbiotes over
there so i wouldn't really be expecting
a symbiote story in the mcu quite just
yet that is not a spider-man related
story but hopefully in an upcoming
spider-man film especially with the teas
in the post-credits scene for the venom
symbiote we eventually do get a null
story and hopefully that's the next
story we get in spider-man 4. but here's
some interesting news about the
fantastic four now of course we've all
been waiting for a very long time now to
know who was going to be playing the
members of the fantastic four and of
course everybody really really really
wants john krasinski to play mr
fantastic i do as well i think it would
be a great choice there's been rumors
that he might appear in multiverse of
madness as a variant but perhaps not
actually play the real mr fantastic that
is coming to the mcu and of course there
have been rumors that he has already
been cast as mr fantastic in the mcu
there's conflicting reports out there
but the latest comes from the twitter
account viewer anon in which this person
has been right about things in the past
this person tweeted a while ago in
january that he heard mr fantastic is in
multiverse of madness but it's not going
to be played by krazynski however
yesterday he tweeted stating i think
it's krazynski i've talked to a few
people since who are pretty sure so we
could be seeing john krasinski as mr
fantastic in the mcu and multiverse of
madness however we still don't know if
this is simply going to be a variant and
john krasinski isn't going to be playing
the main mcu mr fantastic or if he's
going to be the main mr fantastic now he
could be both variants do exist that
look exactly like each other and that
could simply be the case here but right
now it's all just rumors but fingers
crossed that he does play the main mcu
mr fantastic because i think it would be
a spot on casting choice now we have
some interesting news about black
panther 2. angela bessette today was on
the ellen degeneres show and she briefly
talked about black panther 2. now of
course angela plays raimonda queen
ramonda and mother of t'challa black
panther of course everybody has been
wondering what the story is going to be
for black panther 2 especially since
they stated they are not going to recast
t'challa slash black panther so people
are kind of concerned and are wondering
what the story is going to be but here's
what she said on the show she said that
the sequel is going to be even bigger
than the first one and she called ryan
coogler the director of the first one
and the second one the perfect leader
she said and i quote it's going to be
amazing it's going to top the first one
can i say that so right here angela
bessette stated that black panther 2 is
going to be better than black panther 1
which is very interesting considering
that we might not actually have a black
panther throughout the entire film keep
in mind kevin feige said they're not
recasting t'challa he didn't say that
there's not going to be another black
panther there are several people that
the black panther title could fall to
such as shuri umbaku heck they could
even bring in a variant of black panther
himself or killmonger so we could get a
new black panther just not a new
t'challa now some of the story for black
panther 2 is that neymar the submariner
and atlantis are going to be in the film
and be a pretty decent plot point and
rumors had it for a while that actor
tinak huerta is going to be playing
namor and what's very interesting is
that right now he is currently filming
in puerto rico where black panther will
kind of forever is shooting so it does
seem like we have our neymar in
tenacouerta and the very last thing i
want to state today is about morbius
nick santos from the hashtag show
tweeted this today i've seen a nearly
final cut of morbius it's a messy film
doesn't know what universe it's in or
what characters it co-exists with it
definitely isn't the well-oiled machine
that the mcu is some people will like it
but for most it's going to be hard to
get behind so not such good news here
for morbius and this is honestly what i
feared about the movie hopefully it'll
be somewhat well put together and
hopefully it'll be entertaining but i am
kind of worried now but let's just wait
and watch it to see what we think about
it in the meantime let me know what you
think about all of this exciting news in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all things happening
with marvel for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me